donald trump had a full complete and
total meltdown
because his former attorney general
william barr we now know
admitted
there's no evidence of any materially
significant fraud that would have
affected the election results in even a
single state now that this is you know
when we talk about election fraud and
election integrity there will often be
this question posed
by people on the right who will say
are you sure
that no one voted twice
are you sure that there was not a single
instance of fraudulent voting and that's
the wrong question to be asking i have
explained from the beginning the
question is
do we have any evidence
that materially significant fraud took
place
that would even
maybe change the results of a single
state and remember that if you just flip
georgia biden still wins
if you just flip arizona biden still
wins okay and and the answer to that is
no so we can't let them get us off on
the wrong question and along those lines
there's a new atlantic piece very very
interesting piece about william barr
uh which says
uh oh and the the piece is um written by
jonathan carl it's called inside william
barr's breakup with trump
this is a really interesting piece not
because it makes william barr look good
william barr is one of the most
disgusting and depraved attorneys
general
it's just that even barr had no choice
but to say you know you didn't win
um the article writes it's fascinating
in a series of interviews with me this
spring barr spoke for the first time
about the events surrounding his breakup
with trump i have also spoken with
senior officials in the trump white
house and justice department who
provided additional details about barr's
actions and the former president's
explosive response barr and those close
to him have a reason to tell his version
of this story he has been widely seen as
a trump lackey who politicized the
justice department but when the big
moment came after the election he defied
the president who expected to do his
bidding this language
of mike pence defied trump on january 6
then he didn't do
well what right
william barr
defied trump
it may be in some really narrow sense
accurate that they didn't do the thing
trump wanted them to do
but they didn't really have a choice
mike pence can't stop
the election from going forward and joe
biden from becoming president of the
united states trump might think pence
could have done that but pence couldn't
do that and much the same way in in any
real sense i mean barr could have
attempted things which would have
violated
all sorts of law and the way that
elections are run but in reality the the
the the defiance that we saw from
william barr was just well no he you he
can't get involved there's nothing that
he can actually do
and the article goes on to say bars
betrayal this is amazing bars betrayal
came on december 1 over lunch in the
attorney general's private dining room
with michael balsamo a justice
department beat reporter at the ap
also in attendance were the doj chief of
staff will levy and spokesperson carrie
kupeck balsamo was not told the reason
for the invitation when barr dropped his
bombshell between bites of salad he
mumbled and balsamo wasn't sure that he
had caught what attorney general had
said just to be general balsamo said are
you saying
sir i think you better repeat what you
just said kupek interjected barr
repeated to date
we have not seen fraud
on a scale that could have affected a
different outcome in the election
this time balsamo heard him
balsamo's story appeared on the ap new
wire shortly after lunch disputing
donald trump's persistent baseless
claims attorney general william barr
declared tuesday the u.s justice
department had uncovered no evidence of
widespread voter fraud that could change
the outcome of the 2020 election
once this report
went public
donald trump went absolutely and
completely insane and now of course
trump has a full and complete meltdown
this happened a couple days ago while we
were on our vacation a statement by
donald j trump look at this look at how
quickly trump turns on people
rhino former attorney general bill barr
failed to investigate election fraud now
that's untrue
even though it's unclear barr should
have been involved in looking into it
barr did look into it and he found no
material materially significant fraud
trump goes on and really let down the
american people
i would argue the american people are
not let down when democracy actually
gets the right the person who won into
office that's how democracy works
even the scam that took place in georgia
of ballot stuffing on camera he couldn't
see what was wrong with it now that's a
completely bogus conspiracy it's been
widely debunked
just like he failed to understand the
horowitz report and let everyone down
with respect to getting a timely
investigation where's durham on all of
the corruption of the obama biden
administration
he goes on to say
and this is slightly off screen for
which i apologize it's people in
authority like bill barr that allow the
crazed radical left to succeed he and
other rhinos in the republican party are
being used in order to try to convince
people that the election was legitimate
when so many incredible facts now come
out to show conclusively that it wasn't
none of that is true trump fully melting
down
and now going after william barr
even going further trump writing if he
felt this boy why did barr say he was
greatly honored and proud to have played
a role in the many successes and
unprecedented achievements you have
delivered to the american people in the
final letter he wrote to me because
barr's a politician and he's going out
with a completely standard meaningless
pseudo-suck-up letter of no value
whatsoever
he said few could have weathered these
attacks much less forge ahead with a
positive program for the country
william barr may believe that and yet
have found no voter fraud these are not
mutually exclusive things
trump also finishing this off by saying
now it was revealed that barr was being
pushed to tell lies about the election
by mitch mcconnell another beauty who
was worried about damaging the
republican chances in the georgia runoff
what really damaged the senate
republicans was allowing
their races to be rigged and stolen and
worse the american people to no longer
believe their vote matters because
spineless rhinos like william barr and
mitch mcconnell did nothing
um here's my message on this is crazy
out of this world stuff i mean just
of
not almost nothing he's saying is true
he got william barr's name right
he got he correctly claimed there were
runoffs in georgia that's true
everything else is lies
as cartoonish as this is
do not get complacent
the midterms are starting essentially in
three months the midterm season starts
unless we want a repeat of obama's 2010
situation
we have to come out and vote
then there's 2024.
i already told you yesterday a trump
2024 ticket against biden and or kamala
harris
i don't think looks particularly good
and especially if republicans have a
strong 2022 midterm
2024 trump versus biden or trump versus
harris scares me significantly
um
last thought on this
every time
trump supporters say
we like trump because he just he's he
cares about america and he's good for
the country
look at these statements
look at these lies and there is
he will say
he will attack american democracy in
absolutely any way that he sees
advantageous to him he doesn't care
about the country he certainly doesn't
care about his supporters and he cares
about them and other people only to the
extent that they are politically useful
to him they're about to get useful again
his supporters are about to get useful
again because he needs their money so
that he can play king maker in 2022. i
can't think of anything less patriotic
and trump just melting down on and
anyone who simply said mr president i
wasn't able to find any evidence that
you actually won
those now become enemies and they now
become rhinos and unpatriotic or
whatever the case may be it's disgusting
i can't think of anything less patriotic
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram make sure you're following us
there at david pakman show
if your job requires you to know what
people are talking about online or
you're just curious what's being
discussed online check out thought
leaders which has an awesome data
platform that scrapes through youtube
podcasts newsletters every day and
analyzes what is in the content and then
they turn that data into customizable
graphs whether that's a brand a person a
topic anything else you want to explore
companies can see where their
competitors have been mentioned
marketers can see what trends are on the
rise before planning strategy or content
creators like me can see what topics and
themes are being featured on other shows
for example you can see here i can track
what podcasts are discussing the midterm
elections or i can see how many youtube
channels are talking about rudy giuliani
or i can even see what shows have
mentioned me by searching my own name
and you can use this for free
that's free forever
sign up today create your own instant
thought leaders trends report now the
link is down below